did you guys watch the fights yeah oh
we're not yes earlier I saw yeah Maz
Badal the fastest knockout ever I love
that guy
you know what dude I love Ben Askren
though - I like both of them he's corny
corny - me too and I why do you like
Mazda Patel and I'm going to tell you
the reason why I like Maspeth all
because of his like street fight [ __ ]
that he used to back in the day yeah the
fact that he could take that and become
a contender in the UFC is amazing to me
yeah me too
and I also believe that he is real he
scares me he scares you yeah but the
things you know complaining cuz okay so
if you're not if you're not watching the
UFC this guy named Ben Askren who is new
to UFC but he's an undefeated guy from
Bellator 121 I've seen what F Sam was a
champion been around for a long under
got him masada who they had beef and um
Ben Askren gets knocked out in five
seconds a guy that's never lost before
over sure so people giving a Maz well
[ __ ] for celebrating the way dead so why
the first thing he did was well because
phen Askren could have died oh look at
the size of his head I know it's fine
that's true and he's never been knocked
out before I mean actually defended that
when he was on Ariel Helwani show he was
like yeah if you would have asked me if
he was gonna throw some extra shots at
the end I would have been like yeah
that's absolutely something he would
have done like that's fully expected
yeah but when a guy's knocked out to the
point where he's still like this nobody
gave the thumbs up he was still good
solid respect like this and then Maz
Vidale decides the best thing yet to
fall on his back and do the same thing
hilarious I missed that part it was so
funny yeah he leans down he falls down
like this but then in my head cuz my
brother and I were like he could have
died so how bad would you have felt if
he went out like this I don't over and
the guy was dead [ __ ] that I think kind
of funny I think hey Maz Badal is a
serial killer I think he's a [ __ ]
serial killer the way he jokes in the
way he says things and how he repeats
stories yeah it's not real life yeah
yeah yeah I was defensive I had my
hands behind my back that's some hood
[ __ ] that means you [ __ ] somebody up
yeah yeah this means I'm gonna sock you
in the face but in his defense he goes
that's a hoodlum I'm like bro what are
you talking yeah I know so when I when I
saw them just face off yeah I I thought
if you look at Ben Askren been astronaut
novice cuz he's a crazy person yeah you
know cuz he's not really talking to
somebody who's like here on the yeah
yeah that's a very good observation
scared the [ __ ] out of me just looking
I'm smile I was like oh yeah like nobody
who would get in the cage with this guy
yeah and then what are those guys that's
been around so long that naturally you
would think that oh you know he's fading
a bit but he just keeps getting better
and better
yeah that's another thing is it cuz I
didn't see him fight until Darren till I
didn't know who you wanted really until
there until oh really but then once I
saw BB tear until I did research and I
watched all his fights from his
beginning of his career because I have
UFC fight pass even when he loses or
he's lost before just by her
I know exactly but no matter what always
exciting yeah yeah exciting and he's
great and then um what else did you see
like that night amanda Nunez just Holly
Holm mu L is such a weird fight though
just because of how timid Holly was I
think when she felt first of all I
didn't realize like a man in nuna's had
bear claws for hands did you see her
mittens they were she looked like Mickey
Mouse she just kicked her upside that
[ __ ] Holly Holmes but Holly Holly I
thought made a really like big mistake
there and I think that's a but that's
what scary about Amanda she just needs a
tiny tiny error yeah out of her opponent
and then she it's over I actually don't
know why Amanda noonas started becoming
so great because I remember when she
started off she had a very shaky stuff
she did so what happened like what I
remember she fought it was it Raquel
Pennington I think she lost a chasm god
I remember that yeah it and she just got
her [ __ ] together it's a change campus
I'm sure it's this friend yep dong I'm
sorry it's you know a lot of stand-ups
are shitty for many many years but then
one day they just have one show that
everything clicks and then there are
different comedian after that night it
takes sometimes a while some people are
good right away like ship
hell I heard when he was 16 was good
right away Robin Williams is great right
away but there's some people that took
forever and there's a spark yeah and
then like you know someone like
Sebastian Maniscalco who I wouldn't say
was somebody that you would bet on to be
the greatest but over the he just became
better and he didn't even know where his
limit was he's still growing he's
getting better it's scary that dude is a
beast
but yet when I saw him back in the day I
even came up to my said don't do it
again your stand-up is terrible why did
you go out of your way to say that
because he was a friend he was a friend
you know in the beginning I was someone
that had been around a little longer and
I was just like it's not good but then
like he start kept sticking around and
became better and better and that's what
happens some people are journeyman and
they get better as they get older you
know how like there's some fighters
where after a loss they it's almost like
energizes them and all their fights
after that are amazing like Robert
Whittaker right yeah but then there are
others who just yeah they're like at you
dude GSP yeah he's a big one I was like
wow this guy's so boring I respect them
but I don't like watching him fight yeah
but I mean like you know what really
bummed me out was Luke Rockhold that
fall broke his jaw so many [ __ ] times
yeah and he just it's with the same hit
the left hook yeah like come on bro wow
you know much about you know a lot about
it let's go you two it's I'm alright now
I don't know that much so is that what
happened this weekend sporting wise yeah
they came over yeah yeah we just watch
the fights because I you guys could
really shame everyone in this place it's
putting shame on America Wow okay you
met women's soccer yeah that's what
happened well cuz it's soccer damn it
woman's luck watches that in America USA
one bro I don't care okay